first of all what i was like it was for
okay
the entire this entire place erupted
after that performance like people were
losing their minds it was so haunting it
was so dope it was so colorful
how are you feeling like what's going
through your minds right now i wanna do
it again
i wanna do it again
i am never walking down a flight of
stairs by myself he's just gonna carry
from my neck from now on yes
i mind i'm going down the flight of
stairs right now i'm just taking back
like in the beginning of the week yeah
when she was telling me just the ideas
of it
i was amused i was laughing i laughed it
off
but in my mind i'm like that's a lot of
trust to be putting on somebody that
you know what i mean this ain't really
my arena um and it is now yeah
throughout the throughout the the week i
started realizing you know if i was
gonna do it dance
contemporary school yeah
i'm pretty sure you've made history
tying
the furthest that nba player has even
made it for sure how do we feel about
that i don't think anyone has ever
gotten a perfect square from the nba
trying to give good representation for
my brothers man you know for the
association man this is for y'all yeah
yeah
um
oh for the association bro this is for
y'all they said we can't dance we tall
two left feet that's what they said
oh uh i ain't even got eyebrows on right
now
maybe it's the eyebrows maybe we should
just never dance with eyebrows
your wife has had some incredible iconic
performances i really feel like this was
your iconic performance
my favorite performance this was a big
moment as a dancer this was special how
are you going home tonight that's what i
want to know what are you saying um
thank you
uh
probably more of a thank you to juni and
roo cause they've been
they couldn't wait to do all the moves
that i told her we practiced
so i got junior i'm spinning her around
by her feet spinning rule around by her
hands
but tiana just constantly texting me
there's times that she doesn't know the
actual dance style and she's like
texting me pointless hey i watched this
youtube video
i saw this my friend told me this he
danced his ballroom he said you got to
do this you got to stand like this and
she's all about just giving a
performance so she doesn't lean so much
on
uh the structure part she's like no
danielle is perfect for that she got you
straight yeah like the fact that you can
do a rondae is crazy
like that's crazy that you can do that
so yeah rendezvous i'm very proud that
just made me very proud as i can lingo
down you know as long as i can you know
soak up the right terminologies and
uh
you know the right form with her i think
that given the performance my wife's
always going to encourage me to try and
give her all out
well it was so good it was my favorite
thank you congratulations association
this is for y'all no eyebrows
for y'all
and for danny cause
i'm throwing people by their neck now